exciting updates for ibm cloud
schematics
a new ibm cloud billing model and 10 off
intel based bare metal servers
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
to get the ball rolling this week let's
take a look at some new features and
capabilities we've released
in ibm cloud schematics in particular
there are three that i'm going to focus
on
first you can now streamline the
installation of the ibm cloud provider
by pulling directly from the terraform
registry this is great news
because you no longer need to manually
install and configure the provider
and you can specify the exact version
that you want to work against
schematics now supports terraform
version 0.13
this version comes with a number of
improvements including the ability to
specify
third-party providers or modules within
your terraform configuration
and third we're currently in closed beta
for ansible action support in schematics
red hat's open source ansible is an
industry leader for infrastructure
automation
primarily used for configuration
management ansible gracefully picks up
where terraform leaves off
to get the full details on these new
features check out the blog i've got
linked below
next up i'd like to introduce a new ibm
cloud billing model to help you
optimize your business the model is
called cloud pay-as-you-go with
committed use
with it you commit to spend a certain
amount on ibm cloud
and receive discounts across the cloud
platform you are billed monthly based on
your usage
and unlike a subscription you continue
to receive a discount
even after you reach your yearly
committed amount so
how does this benefit you well first
there's the consumption billing
you're invoiced at the service level for
what you consume each month
second there are no penalties for
overage charges if you spend more than
the amount you committed to
you will continue to receive the same
discounts agreed upon by ibm
and third you'll enjoy an improved
console experience where you can easily
visualize the progress towards a
commitment
to learn more about the new ibm cloud
building model check out the link below
to finish things off today i'm going to
bring you a little deal
within the ibm cloud customer portal
you'll now find new options for custom
image support
on ibm cloud bare metal servers by
leveraging our existing image template
library
you'll be able to achieve golden images
on compatible hardware
this saves you time and eases the work
required for scaling and migration
and to promote these new custom image
support features we're celebrating with
a limited time offer
10 off on select 4 and 12 drive 2nd gen
intel xeon dual processor servers to see
a full list of the qualifying server
options and learn how to redeem this
great promo
hit the link below thanks so much for
joining me today for this episode of ibm
cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now